cette galette sera l'une des toutes
dernières à pénétrer dans le château
royal d'amboise son auteur boulangers
pâtissiers de son étape compte sur elle
pour tenter de remporter le concours de
la meilleure galette de l'année une
épreuve qu'il ne manquerait pour rien au
monde
ça met en avant notre savoir-faire les
galettes maison on est un peu décrié en
ce moment avec beaucoup de boulangers
qui font pas leurs galettes
nous on l'a fait on est fiers de la
faire donc donc voilà et ce boulanger
n'est pas le seul prétendant au total 33
galette vont concourir cette année si la
catégorie
osa membres et aussi la galette revisité
à la banco 12h30 le jury est bien là au
grand complet
ils sont professionnels anciens lauréats
ou simples consommateurs ce sont eux qui
vont évaluer ces merveilles pâtissière
les critères sont nombreux en tout
premier lieu notre bonne galette doit
être belle et de taille réglementaire
les jurys sont intraitables la précision
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on en a
besoin c'est un concours et le concours
nous demande 26 cm cuite donc je pense
que en tant que jury faut regarder ça
aussi la liberté est un peu plus grande
dans la catégorie des recettes
revisitées
mais là encore les pâtissiers doivent
démontrer leur maîtrise technique
est-ce que je vais regarder surtout si
elles feuilletage et la cuisson
également sur l'extérieur arrive l'heure
de la découpe la moitié de chacune de
ces pâtisseries sera bientôt offerte aux
restos du coeur
mais en attendant l'autre moitié est
scrutée et goûter avec de bonnes et
parfois de moins bonnes surprises on
sent la frangipane mais on semble pas
l'abricot d'abricot pourtant c'est le
thème et là je sens pas trop la brique
de l'abricot toutes les galettes ont
vraiment un beau différences et ses
impressions à la basse et la même
recette de feuilletage plus ou moins
beau tout le monde il ya plus ou moins
salée plus ou moins croquant pouces
clients
humble tendre c'est la boulangerie
laurent à loches qui a remporté le titre
de meilleure galette revisité à
l'abricot la pâtisserie tourangelle
autour des gourmandises se hisse quant à
elle à la première place dans la
catégorie frangipane